el favor de los ex intérpretes de las
fuerzas extranjeras aumenta a medida que
los talibán ganan terreno en afganistán
las tropas de la coalición deben
abandonar definitivamente el país antes
del 11 de septiembre a pesar de los
anuncios del 14 de julio donde la casa
blanca se comprometió a evacuar sus
aliados y otros individuos valientes al
inp quien trabajó para las fuerzas
estadounidenses en kabul entre 2018 y
2020 pero cuyo contrato fue interrumpido
al cabo de dos años de servicio está
preocupado y apuesta averiguarlo de
tuvisa
mi solicitud fue rechazada entonces
radique otra de inmediato
así cuenta con documentos de peso en mi
expediente no sé por qué no me otorgan
la visa
porque sigo recibiendo una carta de
rechazo no soy el único en este caso
otros intérpretes están en la misma
situación
desde el anuncio de retiro de las tropas
extranjeras su madre quien vivió bajo el
régimen talibán en los 90 está muy
angustiada
no me arrepiento de que mi hijo haya
trabajado para eeuu
carlito con los buenos pero ahora estoy
preocupada por encia y quiero que se
vaya de aquí
y guardó los documentos correspondientes
a los dos años durante los cuales
trabajó junto a los soldados
estadounidenses articket for my team
este es un certificado del equipo con el
cual trabajé durante nueve meses estoy
aquí
los talibán afirman que no se les hará
ningún daño a los ex intérpretes de las
fuerzas extranjeras si expresan su
arrepentimiento al y no les cree
en cuanto a las tropas estadounidenses
se retiren de afganistán
seremos degollados unos tras otros tal
vez los talibán los capturen primero
luego nos torturaron
finalmente firmarán y lo publicarán en
las redes sociales de cabida la protegen
son son media los ex intérpretes quieren
alertar sobre su suerte con frecuencia
organizan reuniones como ésta en kabul a
pesar del riesgo de transformarse en
blancos lo requiso a todas las personas
que ingresan para verificar que nadie en
armas o ejércitos una asociación de ex
intérpretes del ejército estadounidense
inició esta movilización para reclamar
una evacuación inmediata de afganistán
puede escribir mi nombre donde trabajo
trabajé con el ejército francés en el
mar
nacer fue intérprete del ejército
francés entre 2011 y 2012 su pueblo
natal está controlado por los talibán
tras cinco solicitudes de visas
rechazadas por francia está desesperado
cada salida es un riesgo
y nadie
[Música]
ya cada seis meses dos o tres cambios de
casa me escondo así
de repente los ex intérpretes de el
ejército estadounidense protestan le
hacen un llamado del presidente de ese
país
[Aplausos]
[Música]
joe biden afirmó hace poco que aquellos
que habían ayudado a eeuu no serían
abandonados para algunos ya es muy tarde
este es paradís aún estaba vivo el mes
pasado fue degollado por los talibán
pensábamos que el gobierno
estadounidense traería más al cannabis y
que contaríamos con un país estable pero
la situación está peor ahora que hace 10
años
dice que él
en la periferia de kabul ahmad nos
conduce donde el hermano de su amigo
sohail vardis asesinado el pasado mes de
mayo
el hermano de sohail barbie sigue
afectado por la muerte de su hermano
los talibán los siguieron y los sacaron
de su vehículo y empezaron a golpearlo y
con un cuchillo le cortaron la garganta
allá murió
choco meses
a wahidullah le cuesta mantenerse sin
embargo se ocupa con su esposa de la
hija de su hermano asesinado
aída tiene nueve años sufre una
discapacidad mental su madre murió el
año pasado de kobe a los 33 años se
preocupaba diariamente por su marido
porque había trabajado para los
extranjeros cuando salía si fuese por
cinco minutos lo llamaba para estar
tranquila le repetía que no saliera a
menos que fuese necesario debido al
peligro el que se exponía
semanalmente para ti tú la visita a la
tumba de su hermano con mucha tristeza
si no hacen nada por los otros
intérpretes entonces terminarán como él
aquí porque los talibán nunca los
perdonan
y cientos de ex intérpretes y empleados
de los ejércitos extranjeros cuyas
solicitudes de visa fueron rechazadas
temen por sus vidas entre ellos muchos
trabajaron para el ejército francés